AS EVEN PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
ING IN A RAR
NS REALLY, REALLY . WS ARTC T 4
FAS T INFLATION INED
THE THREATO THE ECONOMY IS SHAR.
THE GOh HEARINGS
ARE CI WEED
THCOMMITTEE ISEC MOVE
SURE ON E OFFICIALS TOHA
ELECTIONS.ALS FRE EXPE T
THE GEORGIA SECRETAR
OF STATEE
RAFFENSPERGER BEATS DURING A
LONG, LONG CALL.
WANT TOD 11
S, TN WEHAVE,
>> WHAT ESMESE?
HERE WITH OWSIVELY IS
THN LEADING THE NEXT ING, INTELI
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER OF THE COMM
K YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINMEREADY K
THAT PHONE
CALL W PLAYED.
WHAT AOU GOING TO REVEAL NEW
>> YOU KNOW, LIKE MOST OTHNA?
HEARGS'LL BE A TNG ARENA AND A
NEW INFORMATION.
HINK IS MOST ANIS WTELL THELIC T
ANOTHER, ONE PRESSURE AIGN ON T
THE VICE'S LIFE INDAWE'LL HEAR
ABOUT HOW A
CATED AGAINST STATE ANTIONS CIEN
PDE WAS
TOLD THIS ESSENTIALL
HIS LAWYERS
BUT YET HE U
PEOPLE'S
AND OU MH AT.
N THOUGH LOST FAKE ELECTORAL COE
THESE STATES WE'RE TKI HARD CAM
FI TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS WERE INVOLVED IN
YE EVIDENCET TH
FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSE
>>.SHOW EVIDENCE OF ESIDENT'S
SCHEME.ALAGAIN, SIDENCE H LAWYE
TO THINK ABOUTS WE COURAGEE
OOD UPND
THEY WOULDN'H THIS
O SESSION OR R CALAT
S LDTONSD ECONUSE
A LOT HEPUBLICANS AS
INLVN T TO BE CLEAR, YOU SD YOUT
PUTTING A FAKE SLATEF ELECTORSOD
>> YOU KNOW, IT TO GETAHEAD OF I
'LL OWING WHAT
THE PRESIDT' WAS IN
TRYING TO GET
ALTERNATE SLF RS,  SCHEMIALLY O
LEGISLATURES WOULD RECONVENED F
WIANYWAY.
>> WILL WE SEE IT? WANTOF E R CE
TO GINNI THOMAS, THE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE CLARENCE
CATIONN GINNI THOMAS AND
LAER OVERTURN THE ELECTION, JOH.
ATU HAVE FOR
HER?
>> WE WANTKNOW WHAHAT HELVEMENT
OT TOVERTURN TTION.
E HAS SAID SHE I IN AND TESTY
E WITH PERNEO HEART.
INFORMATIO TO HEAR
TO ASK HER
WILL BINTERER THINGS, WHET SEWI
SES IMPACTING WHETR WE W
>> ANSWER TOION IS YES, DO YOUA
RESIG, RH
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED? I THINK AS
OMAS TO E CE OOPO DO WITANTING .
PARTICULARLY REGNG
INVESTIGATION.E, YOU KNOW, WE W
WHAT - OOCD
PROPRIETY.
>> SOME INFORMATION PRA CONFIDET
YOU KNOW THIS.
YOU'RINOPLEGS
TOHI
HE JUSTIT GOING
FI IS, RIMINALRG?
YOU GIVEN EVERYTHING OVER TO THE
NEENTIALLY DO Y Y EYHAT THEY ARE
>> I D THINK CONGRESS HAAT.
I'VE BN PARTICINSEVERAL INVESTI
INVESTIGATIONS DONE BY
JUSTIC
COSS HEY,
PAMER
SA TO GOGH.
OVLER
WHEN T DEPARTMENT ASKSINGS
WE'RE LOING AT A WE'REVESTIGATI
OUT, JEPTM WANT TONT
THE SUBPOENA PER C JURY, ESSES.
TRADITIONAY THEYON TO DO THAT  R
TH.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO W
THEMEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL ININGINL
INTO THCONVERSATIONS WE'VE >>Y
INTO THE FPRESIDENT?
>> YOU KNOW, JUSOK
PUBLIC RECORD, I HE NOT SEFOR E
CONVENED, IF THEY WERE LOOKING
EXAMPLE, THAT JUDGE CARTER I
LITENGAGED IN
S THATLACRIMIN L
>>'V CRI JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR
WH ASKING T THEMO PARTICE
OUR INTENTIO WE NCTHE INAK
D WE'RE DOONSISTENT  THE -R BRA
>> WE'VE SEE T HUNDREDS,
EN CLOSED DOOR
COWH CALLING AY WHO E COMMITTEE?
T INTENTNAU DON'T WANT TO DEVIA
U'RE TRYING TO
PRES THE PUBLIC POTENTIALLY TO
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
FRANKLY, ANYONE AT HAS WIN
RELEVA
RELEVANT
EVIDENCE BEFORE THE BL
WE'RE DOING IT IN THAT
THE MOST COHESIVE AND E N GEAC
POINTS TO E
>> WHY NOTENE? ASKED HIM
ARILY.
HAPPEN.
>> WE'RE NOT TAKINMS OF WITNESSE
WHO VE NOT YET TESTIFIED.WE WOUO
EVERAL HIGH-PROFILE PEOP
BUT AT THE CAN  WHAT PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS MAY OR MAYT TOERTL